position white has the advantage but
anything can happen 20 seconds against
15 seconds only two second increment
it's not online where you can pre-move
it's literally to the death and hey
Archer and keeping an eye on white
spawns
throwing a trade now Prague he's giving
up his 8.4 black speed Pawn all right
tonight holding everything together
yes Little Pigs therefore it can be met
by look takes B6
[Music]
strong
instead of Queen trade
under the 10 second Mark for Eric icy
oh you can see the nurse changing his
mind with seconds to spare King H7
why has an extra Pawn it's five versus
four
yes because Ruby it was a big big
problem he did not want to trade that
look
[Music]
unless the counter play Blacks pawns all
separated especially the C5 upon
scattered white defending controlling
everything oh two seconds one second for
Eric I see
[Music]
Prague got excited there you can see him
looking at the clock
he's sticking down now he made it with
one second as well
even with the two seconds increment we
see flying pieces
I think we'll see more pieces fly but
white king is coming white is winning
this end game White's Rooks are about to
land on the seventh rank
okay this is scramble on the clock a
second Pawn Falls ericice he has a
hopeless position but he's got time on
the clock
this is one Saving Grace right now
[Music]
all bets are off
making moves with one second two second
every single turn
axrook almost trapped how does Prague
finish this off
you think the clock will play a factor
here
barely pours for breath
if white can get accumulate sometime
then it's completely winning but Arjun
is keeping on blitzing not a link
to
think
and E6 by Prague there has Prague let it
slip he thought he was checkmating maybe
then panicking he's given up some of his
Advantage but he's still going to stay
with a two-point edge here and Eric icy
needs to find a miracle
for The Rook trade
there we go ganging up on the E6 Pawn
yes
now back on track
almost guaranteed at this point white
has two extra performance connected
Black's King is cut off White's moves
are automatic he's gonna gain time on
the Block he's going to win
Arjun it's in a hopeless situation here
If This Were online you would pre-move
to the end now White's about to make a
new Queen
and Arjun offers his hand after all of
that pragnananda is the one to win and
will advance to the semi-finals
wow incredible what a drama and we have
seen that that extra two seconds made
such a huge difference